la troisième urgence qui est devant nous
c'est celle bien évidemment de la
négociation tac et quota de la fin
d'année alors là aussi je vais le dire
en toute transparence et en toute vérité
elle va être très très très compliquée
très compliquée à part peut-être
sur la la partie manche où ce sera un
peu moins simple un peu pardon un peu
plus simple toutes les autres espèces
tous les autres secteurs géographiques
sont dans une situation où c'est une
baisse significative voire
drastique la raison étant que
selon le le conseil scientifique il y a
une baisse du stock qui ne veut pas dire
que c'est dû au pêcheur principalement
ça peut être aussi d'autres facteurs
mais forcé de constater qu'il y a une
baisse de la ressource et donc ça va
avoir un impact sur nos pêcheries et sur
notre secteur de manière très forte
comme l'année dernière bien évidemment
je vais me battre pour à la fois
défendre la souveraineté alimentaire de
la France et défendre tous nos
territoires parce qu'il s'agit pas de
favoriser Paul au détriment de de
Jacques et donc on va le faire avec
trois approches ou en tout cas trois
principes qui me guident et qui nous ont
guidé l'année dernière qui nous permis
là aussi d'avoir un résultat plutôt
positif l'année dernière c'est un se
baser bien évidemment sur la science et
reconnaître les efforts qui ont été
réalisé par nos pêcheurs
de adapter et bien tout ça au territoire
parce que la réalité de la Méditerranée
n'est pas exactement la même que celle
du golf de Gascogne et trois prendre en
compte un des piliers essentiels de la
politique commune des pêche qui est la
viabilité économique de nos entreprises
et et on doit bien prendre en compte le
fait que si jamais nous sommes dans une
situation où il y a une grande partie de
nos entreprises de pèche qui
s'effondrent c'est notre capacité et
bien à maintenir de la souveraineté
alimentaire sur le long terme qui s'en
trouve affecté sachant en plus que dans
le même temps nous avons pas mis en
place des closes miroirs au niveau
européen qui nous empêcherait d'importer
des produits qui n'ont pas les mêmes
standards environnementaux et sociaux
donc ce serait une forme de de folie à
la fois commerciale environnementale et
sociale et donc j'ai rencontré la
semaine dernière pour cette semaine
pardon mon homologue belge euh
néerlandais aussi pour sur ces trois
piliers on part de la science on prend
en compte la viabilité économique des
entreprises comme l'un des piliers
fondamentals de la PCP et on adapte ce
que l'on fait au territoire c'est ce qui
nous permettra je le crois en tout cas
c'est ce que N nous allons porter et
bien d'avoir un résultat qui soit
peut-être euh moins euh négatif que ce
qui est envisagé à l'heure actuelle et
vous pouvez compter sur moi bien
évidemment pour me battre pour tous nos
territoires